japon un peu partie sous les bancs
d'école en faisant un faux pas kelly
professeur sa mère et en en faisant le
logo dans un cours ou de 1,1 griffonnait
quelque part le popoli samuel wallet 21
ans est fondateur et propriétaire de six
nations il a créé cette entreprise alors
qu'il avait 19 ans entre deux cours au
collège où j'aime beaucoup le l'esprit
des hiérarchies oui de besoin d'avoir un
leader mais pas nécessairement argos le
boss votre crier de rémy mais le leader
vont ramer avec tout artiste un peu de
même que je fusse carrés à tout les
jours avec des émissions de télévision
comme dans l'oeil du dragon à l'antenne
de radio-canada encore shark tank et
10.6 sur les ondes des télévisions
américaines et canadiennes anglaises
l'idée de se lancer en affaires et de
devenir son propre patron plaît de plus
en plus aux canadiens cette idée qui
commence est populaire au tournant des
années 2000 est maintenant en pleine
ascension en premier lieu je pense ça
vienne des jeunes qui sont sans aucun
passé universitaire ils ont un intérêt
très marqué très profond pour
l'entreprenariat et non seulement pour
l'entrepreneur dans le monde des
affaires dans les technologies mais
aussi au niveau social
suzanne fortier et vice chancelière de
l'université mcgill à montréal
ce que je remarque qu'en fait c'est
qu'ils arrivent déjà sur nos campus avec
un sens de leadership déjà développé le
goût de mener leur propre initiative de
mener leur propre organisation et ils
sont aussi des gens qui sont très
branchés
depuis son nez dans ce monde là ils sont
nés dans un monde qui change constamment
alors pour eux c'est naturel de vouloir
faire changer les choses
et puis on les a bien formés je pense à
la maison et puis aussi à l'école
primaire et secondaire à développer leur
leadership à l'université ce qu'on voit
beaucoup c'est des initiatives au niveau
de l'innovation sociale nos étudiants
ils sont partout ils ont un sens assez
profonde de l'engagement envers la
communauté
alors ils sont prêts à faire des choses
qui vont bénéficier à leur communauté
lancer des commerces qui sont caractère
de nice mais aussi sociale donc de
participer à la vie de la communauté
oui parce qu'on n'a pas le souci mon
impression
sylvain saint germain et commissaire en
développement d'entreprises spécialisées
en technologie à gatineau au québec donc
aux portes de tahoua la capitale
canadienne chercher que ce soit à mes
employés ou autre c'est l'attention la
jeunesse ou 6 et asseoir d'autonomie a
soif de liberté on on voit sur un
chéneau à gauche et c'est bon ça c'est
joyeux ramène tel c'est pas tous les
acteurs qui utilisent suspects cinq sont
néanmoins des celica vendre des produits
sur des produits d idriss talhi comme
l'énergie qui ont encore une vision veut
pas quelque chose ces joyeuses chose
[Musique]
puis le numéro 2 vraiment où on fait la
production des produits maison
[Musique]
début de loyer 25 ans et propriétaire du
restaurant motel bon voyage à saint
fabien au québec dans mes expériences
professionnelles j'avais travaillé un
peu dans l'institution financière qui
s'élève peu plus tellement je trouve ça
plate un peu trahi dans un bureau où ben
ça vous fait passer pour moi dans le
fond la restauration mais ce métier de
défis je suis lassé mais il n'est pas
nécessaire pour se lancer en affaires
d'assumer toutes les responsabilités
d'un césar et de construire rome
certaines entreprises sont achetés par
leurs propres employés
criant du coup une multitude de patron
un phénomène qui commence est de plus en
plus populaire au pays
on lit souvent ça dans les journaux les
entreprises qui changent de mains qui
sont vendues un nouveau propriétaire qui
sont avalés par un plus gros qu'elle
mais un scénario un peu moins connu
effectivement c'est la reprise de
l'entreprise par les employés eux mêmes
avec des visées plus démocratique c'est
à dire que les employés ont
potentiellement davantage de pouvoir
dans l'entreprise
maiko carlier et président de nova est
une entreprise médiatique spécialisé en
innovation sociale et je vous donne deux
exemples
le premier fait un cas qui a fait jaser
il ya quelques jours au québec celle
annonce de la fermeture d'un des plus
vieux restaurants de la chaîne de
rôtisseries st-hubert pour rappel il ya
un an la chaîne qui compte quand même
plus d'une centaine de restaurants à
travers la province était rachetée par
l'ontarien carats or il y a quelques
jours bien saint-hubert annoncé donc
qu'elle allait fermer l'un de ses plus
vieux restaurants ouverts dans les
années 80 à montréal ce qui conduit
aujourd'hui les quelques soixante dix
employés du restaurant et bien cherché
une solution plutôt que de fermer
purement et simplement ils veulent
racheter ce restaurant en créant une
coopérative de travailleurs donc une
démarche solidaire dont l'objectif est
bien entendu de maintenir les emplois
mais aussi d'opérer d'entreprises sous
une forme de gestion plus participative
en répartissant les responsabilités et
les bénéfices alors ça là ce sont donc
les employés qui cherchent à reprendre
l'entreprise de manière collective mais
parfois celle inverse c'est une
entreprise ce sont les dirigeants
c'est le cas de la brasserie ontarienne
beau parce que l'année dernière à
l'occasion de son dixième anniversaire
et bien l'entreprise a amorcé un
processus de vente de ses actions à ses
employés dont quelque 150 employés
peuvent acquérir des parts de
l'entreprise
pourquoi les dirigeants ont-ils décidé
de faire sa ba notamment pour assurer
l'indépendance de leur entreprise parce
que si le capital est détenu par des
dizaines d'employés
c'est moins facile d'être racheté par un
concurrent par exemple avec le risque
que ça qu'on prendrait de dénaturer la
mission où la culture de l'entreprise
une autre raison c'est aussi consolider
l'équipe quand chacun est un peu
propriétaire donc un peu
décisionnaire on se sent davantage
impliqués et concernés responsable donc
là finalement on cherche à investir
finalement dans la longévité dans la
stabilité de l'entreprise
un reportage de radio canada
international